moi je demande son expulsion immédiate
du territoire il est algérien
il est là pour détourner la loi j'estime
qu'il un comportement d'islamistes en
col blanc et qu' il ferait bien d'être
expulsés du territoire et que ses
comptes bancaires soient fermés donc
quand je vois que par rapport à ce cas
qui est quand même
voilà c'est pas la gravité de l'ensemble
du terrorisme que nous vivons en france
mais quand je vois l'incapacité de
bernard cazeneuve à régler cette
situation qui est pourtant simple à
faire je me dis que je ne vois pas
comment les femmes c'est un moment
qu'elle crée des audiences au à bernard
cazeneuve qui est incapable d'assurer la
sécurité des français dans notre pays et
et moi quand il est venu à toul
j'ai c'est moi qui me suis retrouvé à
être écartée par la police émotionné
case est entré sous protection policière
au centre des impôts
comment voulez vous que les policiers
qui après m'en ont parlé étaient
révoltés des ordres qui peuvent recevoir
c'est insupportable